[Music]
hello I'm Dustin Kirkland and I'm joined
here with Janet quo software engineer at
Google and she's gonna share with us
about of her experience around
kubernetes here at coop Con in in
Copenhagen I understand that working in
the workloads area in kubernetes you've
got some expert perspectives on how
kubernetes is changing the life of an
application developer and an IT
administrator so um yes
so kubernetes absolutely help people
stop thinking about infrastructure or
their computers machines but start
thinking about the things that they
actually cares about like services and
how to run their applications and also
other ecosystems such as sto also help
people to decouple the operations and
developers and make it very easy for
them to work I work independently but
coordinate together yeah so you tell you
that it's really helping application
developers spend time on their
application their code far less so than
on the rest of the infrastructure yeah
and the operations team can work on
things like how do you deploy the
applications and how to manage them how
to manage the policies of those
applications right right
so from a workload perspective what
types of workloads do are you you know
working to improve in kubernetes so when
i first started i and i and kubernetes
only support stateless were closed then
right so I wrote the deployment API okay
then we figured that people need more
than stateless org loads so then we have
the staple set that helps people to run
their say for applications through and
we also have the jobs and con jobs API
for batch processing right and most
recently we have the
native support for kubernetes in spark
okay that's just announced and wild girl
right and then so people if people are
using spark they can run it on
kubernetes native right maybe for just
giving a bit of education to some of the
people watching this can you maybe
explain some of the differences between
stateful stateless and then batch
processing and how that fits into
kubernetes sure so for sillas
applications is things like your web
applications that you may run a multiple
instance of the same thing and they're
seen as disposable so you if something
dies you don't care you just create more
right before stay for applications you
care about their unique identity so each
of your part your instance your
application instance will be similar but
they'll each have their own identity
their storage their network ID writings
like that and for batch processing it's
for you to be able to tell communities
how many part I want to run at a time to
process my jobs right yeah so maybe
state full applications might be
something like a database for instance
yeah database or a clustered application
cluster applications okay stateless
might be something like a web fronting
or a proxy yeah right and then batch
processing might be image yeah image
processing or you have a bunch of email
you want to sent or you want to backup
something and you feel like all three of
those are equally as well supported as
workloads in the in the kubernetes
community today and so the stateless
applications are definitely the most
mature one right but that's where we
started yeah that's what we started and
that's an the most simplest model that
we support and for the other
like batch and stateful workloads
they're still it's also pretty mature
because there are all GA but we have we
keep hearing people's feedback and we
are trying to improve those for example
for batch
some people want index job like they
want better support and we may support
that in core or we may create something
some customized controllers for people
to be able to do their own things
outside of core right and from a
workload perspective what do you think
are maybe some of the most interesting
CN CF and cloud native ecosystem
projects today so there are a bunch of
projects for example the East eel is one
of the ya-ya CN CF project for me and
there are also a lot of people around
were close they are building different
tools for making it easy for you to
write your application or controllers
right like like operators right or like
QB builder things like that mm-hmm
and that's very interesting yeah yeah it
is really interesting so you're involved
with the community quite a bit right
would you say most of your work is done
now most of your engineering work is
done in the public in the in the
kubernetes community at this point yeah
so most of my work lives on github yeah
yeah yeah and what what's been your
experience so far working in the
kubernetes community so the community
has grown a lot and at first we we are
pushing to find more and more people to
write code but now we find that we have
so many PRS to reviews and we are short
on reviewers so we are trying to fix
that by ramping up more contributors
make them own
more code and be one of the reviewers of
some expert areas right yeah now
reviewing code still takes takes a
developer to do or there are other areas
of the community that may be non
developers can get involved from a
kubernetes perspective sure um so for
example Docs is one of the most
appreciated appreciate it yeah so I
remember when I joined where we don't
have so people often criticize like oh
kubernetes doesn't have good dogs or we
cannot understand the dogs you know
right so whipping improving that and we
created more and more on tutorials and
we recently did a dark revamp so if you
go to the kubernetes style website
you'll see the new format kubernetes dot
oh yeah documentation yeah that's great
testing QA of QA I'm involved in SiC
product actually so there's a music p.m.
a product management align so yeah
there's there's quite a few ways to
contribute to kubernetes inside of just
writing and reading code right yeah good
along those lines you have any advice
for any students or young engineers who
are coming to the kubernetes community
perhaps for the first time so for
students I would so we have one
contributor who is called Lucas he's a
he was a high school students one was
the youngest contributor in our
community so I want to call out and to
let people know that don't feel
intimidated to join the kubernetes
community very welcoming community yeah
it's very welcoming and if you don't
know where to start you can just start
with browsing all the six mm-hmm and to
figure out which one you want to join
and you if you don't know which one to
join you can just join the contributor
experience because that's the first you
can you
give feedback like what I see from the
contributor say what process you can
improve right yeah that's great you
called out Lucas is there anyone else in
the kubernetes community that you find
particularly inspiring someone that you
might want to give a shout out to a
public thank you
oh there are so many people yeah for
example Brian Greene
I first worked with him and then Eric
team and for people outside of Google I
would say Clayton is one of the earliest
contributor to kubernetes and hasting he
is being involving in every
conversations and every PRS and he has a
lot of insights right yeah and what one
final question how did you first come to
kubernetes what was your introduction to
kubernetes like so I came to so
kubernetes is my first project at Google
and when I interviewed at Google and I
got a phone call from Tim Hocking and he
just basically sold me the idea because
kubernetes wasn't a thing at that time
yet and a lot of other orchestrating
solutions are much more popular than
kubernetes and people even don't know
how to spell or pronounce so yeah after
getting his phone call I was like I mean
I'm sold
yeah I'm sold very cool well Janet thank
you very much for your time yeah thank
you